[Musique]
selon l'étude de la Banque mondiale sur
la pauvreté et le partage de la
prospérité en 2022 nous avons
aujourd'hui 1,2
milliards de personnes qui vivent dans
une pauvreté aiguë
en la planète
en Afrique subsaharienne
nous avons
389 millions de personnes qui vivent
dans la pauvreté
et l'Afrique subsaharienne abrite 60% de
la pauvreté mondiale et donc quand on
regarde tout ça cette pauvreté extrême
on regarde l'avènement de la covid en
2000 2019-2020
on constate que 70 millions de personnes
ont été conduits dans la pauvreté
719 millions de personnes vivent avec
moins de dos de dollars 15 centimes par
jour
quand on observe tout ça il y a une
certaine tristesse comment construire
ensemble un lendemain meilleur pour
notre futur génération
comment construire ensemble une Afrique
où il faut où il fait bon de vivre pour
notre futur génération et comment
construire ensemble une Guinée prospère
où nos jeunes ne rêveront plus d'aller à
l'étranger à travers la migration
irrégulière
on constate aujourd'hui les effets
mondiaux
par exemple lorsqu'on regarde la balance
d'exportation mondiale
on constate que ceux qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Afrique en Europe en Asie
impact le dernier village qui a eu au
monde
par exemple on constate que le prix du
maïs a augmenté et ceux qui sont dans
l'agriculture vont être d'accord avec
moi qu'aujourd'hui ça ça constitue un
frein et c'est pour ça les œufs coûte
cher c'est pour ça le poulet coûte cher
et donc nous vivons dans un monde
intégré dans un gros village où nous
sommes obligés de surveiller ce qu'on
fait pour ne pas créer un effet néfaste
autour de nous donc quelle est la
solution aujourd'hui pour bâtir une
Guinée prospère
je pense qu'il faut déjà regarder le
taux de pauvreté dans notre pays plus de
55% de la population est pauvre et quand
on regarde la croissance des enfants il
y a une étude que le PAM a sorti nous
avons 24,4% des enfants qui ont des
problèmes de croissance et pour résoudre
cela je pense j'estime
qu'il faut regarder l'éducation
mettre en avant l'éducation parce qu'à
travers l'éducation on peut bâtir un
pays solide et prospère mais comment
amener des enfants pauvres
qui ont leurs besoins primaire qui n'est
pas atteint qui ont faim qui n'ont pas
de quoi porter
de chez moi à taoia d'ici et je sais pas
d'où vous vous
avez quitté pour venir ici je pense que
vous avez dû constater la pauvreté tout
autour les mendiants les femmes qui vont
dans la rue donc l'éducation est
essentielle mais comme on le fait
ensemble comment construire ensemble un
pays solide que je pense que
si on arrive à réussir ce défi
non seulement nous réussirons à voir une
population qui n'est pas manipulable
on réussira à traiter les problèmes liés
au changement climatique
on réussira à relever d'autres défis
politiques je donne un exemple
en 2018 j'étais en tournée en Guinée
pour un fort pour je crois que c'était
une caravane des investissements et
c'était au moment où il y avait les
élections communales et j'ai eu la
malchance de me retrouver à Kindia à la
sortie de Kindia en allant vers maman
dans un quartier qui s'appelle tapioca
et on nous a attaqué il y avait une
embuscade
c'était des enfants qui étaient dans la
tranche d'âge de 8 à 14 ans
personnellement j'ai été attaquée il y
avait 10 véhicules on était une
cinquantaine il y a eu des blessés mais
je me suis dit si ses enfants étaient à
l'école on serait pas dans ce scénario
si les parents de ses enfants avaient
été à l'école ils auraient pas été
manipulés
donc il est très important de mettre
l'éducation au centre de tous ses
problèmes quand on est dans notre
véhicule et qu'on boit de l'eau on jette
on ne sait pas quel est l'effet de ce
geste sur la nature c'est l'éducation
une fois de plus
alors pour ma part
c'était en hiver
nous étions en 2004 j'étais aux
États-Unis j'étais dans mon bureau
et
j'étais j'avais une pile de dossier sur
la table
très stressé je me posais la question
mais est-ce que c'est ce que je veux
faire de ma vie je gagne bien ma vie
mais est-ce que c'est là où je veux
rester
et des jours avant j'avais accompagné un
ami dans une famille aux États-Unis
comme quoi la pauvreté là-bas aussi
et dans cette famille quand on est
arrivé en quittant il y a un enfant qui
m'a appelé et qui m'a dit même
j'ai faim je me suis dit aux États-Unis
on peut avoir encore des personnes qui
ont faim
alors là ça m'a ça m'a indiqué si ils
ont faim ici chez moi
et ma Guinée et donc le débat interne
que j'avais
j'étais dans mon bureau
m'a permis de prendre la décision que je
voulais impacter
je voulais apporter ma petite
contribution
pour bâtir ma Guinée mais comment le
faire
déjà le premier pas il fallait bien que
je retourne au pays
et j'ai eu l'opportunité
de travailler dans une grande
institution une institution publique qui
a permis aujourd'hui de libéraliser
l'entreprenariat en Guinée parce qu'on
peut créer maintenant une entreprise
Simon une semaine mais minimum 72 heures
j'ai contribué à initier des réformes
qui ont permis d'assainir
l'environnement des affaires en Guinée
la digitalisation par exemple du système
des impôts et pour moi ceci n'avait
pas de prix
pouvoir apporter ma contribution
à travers une équipe et je me rappelle
lorsqu'on a pris fonction le directeur
et moi on voulait bâtir une institution
solide
une institution de référence en Guinée
mais comment le faire
il fallait soutir il fallait les
personnes ressources autour de soi tout
à l'heure quelqu'un la mentionner il
fallait avoir des personnes ressources
pour pouvoir bâtir ensemble construire
ensemble une agence de référence en
Guinée
et je pense qu'on l'a fait mais je
voulais pas m'arrêter là je voulais
continuer à impacter comment impacter
encore plus
comment changer la donne comme apporter
ma petite contribution
c'est là où j'ai décidé d'aller dans le
système des Nations Unies et j'ai eu
l'opportunité de coordonner un projet
d'intégration socio-professionnelle des
jeunes et c'est là où j'ai touché j'ai
vu la vraie misère
la misère dans les fons des districts
guinéens
où les gens avec un franc un dollar un
dollar ils étaient heureux
on a eu accompagner un groupement qui
était assez décoré
l'investissement était moins de 5000
dollars
c'est investissement a impacté plus de
350 personnes autour de ce village
ça n'avait pas de prix encore une fois
pour moi
et donc
quand je regarde tous ces effets
j'ai rencontré des jeunes filles qui
n'avaient plus l'espoir mais qui sait
quand même de travailler par exemple je
rencontrais une jeune fille à Bella qui
faisait qui tissait qui faisait le tissu
mais rien que de nouveau rien que la
petite contribution qui était même pas
de 20300 dollars il avait l'espoir de
vivre
j'ai rencontré des jeunes filles qui ne
savaient pas par où commencer soit pour
entreprendre soit pour trouver un emploi
et à travers
les formations qui étaient offertes on a
pu leur donner de l'espoir et
aujourd'hui j'ai certains qui sont
autour de moi que je continue d'encadrer
et c'est ça ma passion
construire ensemble aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose d'important je pense que
c'est inévitable il faut qu'on le fasse
et c'est possible
c'est possible un exemple
le 2 octobre 2022 à travers ma mère
je suis allé rendre visite à une jeune
fille qui s'appelle massila
qui avait appelé ma mère qui me disait
j'allais mourir
tanti je vais mourir aide-moi s'il te
plaît et ma mère m'a dit s'il te plaît
viens avec moi à l'hôpital pour rendre
visite un massila et quand je suis venu
j'ai trouvé une fille dans une de ces
douleurs
je ne pouvais pas
au fait c'était plus que moi une fille
qui souffrait tant mais qui avait un
petit sourire d'espoir une fille qui à
cause des pesanteurs sociales culturels
qui n'avait rien dit à qui que ce soit
sa grand-mère son père ne savait pas sa
vraie histoire
j'ai prêté mon oreille je l'ai caressais
la tête et je lui ai demandé
dis-moi comment est-ce que tu as eu ce
problème
elle m'a expliqué
et je me suis dit que mais qu'est-ce que
je vais faire pour sauver la fille de
cette fille la vie de cette fille
qu'est-ce que je vais faire
mais c'est là où j'ai vu toute la Guinée
venait ensemble pour aider cette fille
je me suis dit que le bon Dieu m'a
utilisé comme un véhicule pour faire
apparaître ce problème qui était caché
une fille qui était dans un dans une
salle d'hôpital à ignacedine la dernière
salle avant la mort qui était juste
prête à mourir ou tout le monde l'avait
abandonné
et donc là j'ai fait appel à deux
personnes qui m'ont vraiment aidé mes
deux belles-sœurs
une elle était journaliste et une qui
avait un réseau au niveau des hôpitaux
la journaliste a dit écoute je vais
appeler mes amis qui ont des ONG et la
plaie deux ONG et nous j'ai ma vie son
enfance où j'oublie le nom de la ONG et
aussi l'ONG de Moussa Hiro
et l'autre belle-sœur elle m'a dit
écoute je connais la directrice de la
chirurgie d'iniastine on va aller la
voir le dimanche
le dimanche on est allé la voir elle m'a
dit écoute ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
mais cette fille elle a déjà une
septicémie qui commence donc je ne sais
pas si elle va vivre mais si tu
t'engages on peut faire le nécessaire
pour essayer de sauver sa vie donc dès
le lundi déjà tout était activé
nous avons les ONG qui ont commencé à
communiquer sur elle et nous avons aussi
l'hôpital qui a eu les ressources qu'il
fallait pour l'opérer et on avait
l'espoir et massila avait le sourire
vous pouvez voir sur les images on a
tout fait on a fait bouger les choses et
maintenant le gouvernement aussi c'est
engagé et le président s'est engagé à
l'affaire évacuer malgré ça elle avait
l'espoir quand elle arrivait en Tunisie
je me disais déjà en route pour
l'aéroport je pleurais je pleurais de
joie parce qu'on a trouvé une solution
pour massila mais mon inconscient
peut-être pleurait pour dire qu'elle
allait jamais revenir en Guinée
et m'a promis de revenir quand elle est
allée elle a reçu 7 opérations
son corps était fatigué n'a pas survie
survécu
massila son corps est revenu mais là
j'ai vu tout le monde agir chacun a
apporté sa contribution et donc
construire ensemble est possible
maintenant vous qui êtes dans cette
salle j'aimerais que vous vous regardiez
et que vous preniez au fond de vous
l'empathie que vous avez
pour vous dire que tout l'amour que vous
avez vous pouvez le ressentir et pour
vous dire que c'est possible de
construire ensemble
et je vais vous laisser pour vous dire
pour vous demander qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire pour construire une Guinée
meilleure
posez-vous cette question et trouver la
solution le plus vite que possible je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]